another internal today ten people died
in a terrible port there's a huge Bible
after days of torrential rain the
landslide completely buried
killing the inhabitants 32 after takeoff
the planes left-handed you pull up
passengers reported hearing a bang
before fleeing fire and the giant rush
to m1 right we all love watching news of
disasters
it's embarrassing the truth that we like
hearing about car crashes we've really
loved plane crashes fascinated by
landslides we quite enjoy trainer with
fascinated by deadly score concert like
holidaymakers and we're really pretty
gripped by crocodiles
it all looks at the lowest destruction
what monsters we are rubbernecking the
scenes of tragedy on the worst day of
other people's lives but it isn't all
trivial we're trying to get at something
important by looking at tragedy we're
trying somehow to keep in mind that life
is fragile for all of us it might not be
a plane crash that finishes us off or a
fierce crocodile it might just be a slow
cancer or the gradual wearing away of
time but it will happen and yet our
lives go wrong because we don't keep
death in mind and their death is the
most terrible thing but we can evoke the
thought of death to evoke what life
should be about
it's this powerful fact that maybe at
the back of our minds when we rush to
check up on the latest disaster we're
not being ghoulish we're searching for
the meaning of life we're reminding
ourselves to do our hopes and talents
justice in the time that remains the
fruit of death has the power not only to
stir our fears but also to strengthen
our resolve to appreciate more fully and
use more wisely the present moment to
reform our priorities and to be kind
grateful and serious in case tomorrow
never comes
you